hey guys it's Kylie and Jordan here
Kylie Jenner and Jordan Woods are
longtime BFF since eighth grade some are
going into high school but now a source
confirms to ET Jordan isn't staying at
Kylie's home following allegations she
may have hooked up with Khloe
Kardashian's beau
Tristan Thompson our source explained
quote kylie is extremely upset about
everything that is going on with Khloe
and her best friend Jordan Jordan is a
sister to Kylie and she's extremely
shocked this could happen as is the
whole family
another source tells ET that Jordan is
devastated and can't believe how her
world has flipped upside down so fast
adding quote she knows making out with
Tristan was wrong
however our source says Kylie hasn't
made up her mind just yet quote Kylie
needs her space and also wants to
respect her sister Khloe the future of
their friendship hangs on the facts if
my true fans are one enough person will
strengthen things first unraveled on
Tuesday when a source told DT Khloe and
Tristan split over trust issues all
while multiple reports surfaced with
claims of a tryst between Tristan and
Jordan you have to find the happy medium
of keeping your private life private and
you personally you know it's just and
fans are busy tracking social media for
clues Kim Khloe and Kourtney have all
unfollowed Jordan on Instagram
Kim also posted this video to her
Instagram story singing don't mess with
my man by Nivea while we like to tweet
from a fan criticizing Tristan and
Jordan for the alleged incidents
she also seemingly deleted photos with
Tristan from her Instagram I just want
to live my life and be happy despite the
recent drama a source tells ET Chloe and
Kylie are extremely close and this
incident only solidified how strong they
truly are